And nice. Okay.
Up until Yeah, hello, hello.
>> [laughter]
>> Let's do the intro. Yes, let's do the
intro so it's done. Which is like the
hardest part of the video.
Uh okay. So,
are you still using Opus Opus 5.6
and chat GPT? No, still no chat GPT 5.4.
Yeah, yeah, Opus 4.6. Oh Jesus, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah.
Oh.
Are you still using Opus 5.6? You are so
last week.
Um
OpenAI just dropped
uh
GPT 5.4 and it's the best model ever
created. Oh, is it? We don't know. We I
mean, no, we know. We we try to
We will tell you. We know, we know.
>> [laughter]
>> Is that the best model?
Maybe. We tried it uh all last week and
now we are going to
But now we can't we can't say if it's
the best one.
>> We are going to show you. Yeah, exactly.
>> [laughter]
>> And now we are going to show you why.
Did he also say it's the best one? Yeah.
Okay, cool. Nice. Okay, intro done. Clap
clap AI. Yes. Comparing 5.4 versus 4.6.
>> [snorts]
>> Why why don't they call the models like
this is the best Anthropic best model
one best model two?
>> [laughter]
>> It's the it's the same [__] Yeah,
exactly.
So, yeah, man, like
let's let's catch up. How was your week,
man?
Uh
I was doing a lot and then
then we had the new version
and everything went again so much
better.
Uh it's really really good. Like I
switched to and I love
finally
uh OpenAI model.
Yeah, I I even switched back from using
Cloud a lot to using Codex much more.
Uh 100% in a week I did I did I don't
think No, I open
I open Cloud uh
once. So, I have eight eight tabs. Mhm.
Uh and sometimes I open like I have
eight tabs
and sometimes I open another tab to have
more uh
tabs where I open the CLI in each.
And
um
today I had eight tabs of Codex
and I use after day of coding I use 10%
of my weekly
reset which has been reseted like three
times this week. So, thank you for the
bugs.
Okay. And [laughter]
And all eight screens are just ongoing.
Yeah, like uh sessions of everything
just dropping because Okay, so right now
I'm doing QA for Genfeed. And
so, what I do is I have
the background task inside the Codex
CLI. Mhm. So, Codex is listening to uh
the processes
and if there is a React issue on a
background like a root root issue or
like missing a file whatever, then um
it get intercepted right away by the CLI
and fix it right away.
Okay, so it's like a listener. Yeah,
exactly. Yeah,
I run the apps directly from that and
uh yeah, man, like
it's making way less mistakes. I mean,
like on animations of I had some issues
like sidebar animation stuff. Mhm. Cloud
was completely [__] up
and Codex like did a really good job
with like animation of the tabs, you
know, collapse uh
Mhm. collapse [clears throat] the
sidebar and stuff like that. So,
it's
Genfeed is the best app I ever built.
For sure.
>> Yeah, and it's getting better and better
as the AIs get better. Yeah.
So, yeah. What What about you, man?
Yeah, I was just building everything
with Cloud. Mhm. And for example, my my
Zendesk rebuild for my own ticket system
I had some issues when I added a CC to
an email or to a ticket. Uh and Cloud
said it was not completely possible as I
requested
um to show it in [clears throat] the
normal uh email sending way. It had to
do something different and
I just tried it several times and I had
a second issue where it was saying that
I could not easily put images in line. I
had to do everything through attachment.
And I did I didn't check it myself.
Cloud did everything.
>> [laughter]
>> But now I asked Codex 5.4 and within 10
minutes both problems were solved.
And I tried it multiple times with Opus
4.6. What about 5.3?
I didn't because 4.6 was better than
5.3.
What about like planification? Do you
still plan with Cloud, review with Codex
or you do switch it? Yeah, I used to do
it 5.3 in Codex and 4.6 Opus. Mhm. Used
[clears throat] to ask both of them to
create same plan
and just merge it and then have one of
the two build it.
Um
but right now
uh
Opus is doing like 15 minutes of a plan
to 20 minutes when it's a big one.
Research online stuff. And then Codex
5.4 did it in 2 minutes. It's way
faster.
And they have the the fast mode where
you burn double tokens. I didn't even
enable it.
No, like the yeah, like the 5.4 spark?
Yeah. Yeah. I tried because there is
there is another like line of um
uh
usage. Mhm. Yeah, I I never for 5
minutes to say okay, whatever. I don't
care about that. Yeah, they just hope
you enable it and forget it so you burn
double tokens all the time.
I wonder whether have like token all
week instead of just having it just on
Monday.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah.
No, for sure. But I'm not using it. You
can just open two CLIs and just
do two tasks as a one. Then you have the
same result as doing one task double
speed, right? Exactly. I mean, yeah, and
if it's like different scope and stuff
and the files are not even touching on
different part of the app or different
bugs or whatever.
Chop chop like Yeah.
And if it works double as hard, we have
to do the double amount of work as well.
Bro, like
>> [laughter]
>> um I saw a tweet from
Peter levels.io, you know? Mhm. And he
said for the first time in my my life or
like for the last for the first time in
the last 15 years my dashboard is empty.
Yeah.
Like Even if your customers come to you
and keep asking
you know, you're so fast.
I mean
yeah, like
I mean, for Genfeed I would like people
to open PR directly in GitHub instead of
using like, you know, canner canny or
like any feedback stuff. Just have
uh the user entering on GitHub and
whatever and create a PR on issue. Mhm.
Add to the issue and then
you assign the agent
on as a as a triage on it and then
that's it. Yeah, and everything runs by
itself.
Like it makes sense to be a project
manager spending
your time in Ember board.
Yeah, so everything is changing but
I've been doing the 5.4 now for a few
days
and everything that was sitting on the
bench like this is going to take some
extra research or whatever Mhm. or I
have to do a better plan mode,
everything is fixed.
Yeah, nice.
I even switched my open Cloud to 5.4 and
the Discord quality of the manage
messages Yeah. it went up a lot.
Oh, the the quality of of what? Of the
output? Uh of the output. Okay.
So, my conversations and how fast it
responds, I still think it's a lot
better than the previous models I used.
But I I think it's because also your
code base is growing, right? So, like
because the more you code, the more like
new context it needs to ingest with like
new features and stuff. So, it needs to
research again inside the code base so
it get lost and then you have like um
shitty output like I don't know. Maybe
we should do like a weekly review of the
agent like uh
have an open Cloud
uh
job that um
that we just can repeat all the time and
post
the statistics. Like every day every day
you you read the whole code base and you
see you you take the last commit since
the last 24 hours and you update your
documentation. Yeah.
I think I should do that.
And then we stop once we can just say
get me some coffee and it does.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh
recurring recurring
task to document
MD files. Nice. Nice. Nice. I love that.
I love that. I love that. That's
love it.
That can be cool. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, I I think it's like mandatory.
Like I would
I've you digging to like the open claw
architecture like to understand
how it works and how it orchestrate
everything. Yeah, I have been doing it
and then I asked him to improve it. And
I have several setups depending on the
Mac mini that I use. So, it is different
all the time and it every time when it
does a setup and I'm not happy, I just
have himself improve it. And even
sometimes just write him up and let him
write a plan on how he wants to do it,
put it in Codex, put it in Opus.
Ask for feedback, put it back into
Cloudbot. So, then I'm using it like a
triple round.
Triple round how?
Like
Cloudbot needs a plan first before it
creates it. And then I have a check done
by Codex, a check done by Opus. I use
the feedback to put into Cloudbot, say
optimize it. So, I'm using like the
agent and two additional AIs to optimize
the architecture of Cloudbot. And you
still doing that on on the Discord UI or
do you
um
No, the double checking is just copy
paste to the CLI.
Hm.
>> That's
That's just a simple one. So, Hm. I can
do the automation, but that's Yeah, if
it is so so simple. Yeah. I don't want
to do an additional step. Makes sense.
Yeah. Until until you will you will have
like 25 agents that taking each other.
Yeah.
But
it may sound stupid, but
today I was setting up
one Cloudbot with like four
AI bots in it and not agents that it
spawns, but separate AI bots so that
they all have to dedicated task and
their own memory.
And
I also want to have separate config
files, separate API keys and everything.
And I was a bit lost and Opus could not
fix it.
Um Codex gave me some options, but
eventually it didn't fix it properly.
So, I dropped it in another Cloudbot
from another environment from hey, this
is my issue. Uh I need to solve it. How
would you tackle it? And the other
Cloudbot checked its own architecture
and gave me a better result than Opus
and Codex.
Okay.
Why?
I don't know. It worked.
>> [laughter]
>> I I I have serious issue with like open
like it it it
Uh
it's getting home a lot. I don't know if
it's because of the cron job that I give
it like it was like also like [__] up
or even the keys are expiring and but
it's keep like looping on errors and
it's killing my uh
like the RAM I give it on the instance
or even like because everything is on
Tailscale. So, uh I had my
Mac Studio that run to 300 CPU for 2
days
>> [laughter]
>> because I was away and
yeah, an issue with that too. Yeah.
Yeah, I had to watch through Tailscale
to fix everything. Yeah. And yeah, and
it was not working because then there's
another issue to like connect blah blah
blah or no no file because all of the
agent also have
a permission issues. Mhm.
So, then one agent can't write in the
folder of another agent. So, they don't
have
they can't interact with Mac Studio
because it's another
Yeah, and it's not in the same session
or whatever.
So, then you're spending like 10
debugging
another time. I don't know. I I fixed it
by just having one agent who does all
the communication. Hm. And all the other
agents, they can only communicate to the
first one and that one has all the Yeah.
all the setups and everything done
properly because I'm not setting up four
bots and doing all the
assessments and I know whatever for each
one of them. So, you have only one bot
but multiple sub agents. I have like
four bots right now on that on that Mac
mini running. Okay. But there is one
team lead
and he communicates to the other three.
Okay. And he is just in like a
communicator. The other three don't have
all the rights that the the main one
has. Okay.
Are they running products 5.4? Yes. All
of them? Yeah.
Okay.
And do you reduce the reasoning?
Uh not yet because the Mac mini is
running it. But I'm not giving them task
every 10 minutes. They have like daily
tasks. Hm. But I'm I'm also adding
skills to them and they each have their
own skill sets. So, Okay.
it's not like they're doing everything.
Yeah.
And I'm still testing if that's better
than have one big one with many skills.
I don't
The results are really like varying a
lot from one user to
another. That's a problem.
But [clears throat] you can do so many
different setups
because of the MD files for the soul and
everything.
Just just adding different setups that
makes your bot work in a totally
different way if you want to.
And even like from yeah, even one
machine machine for another because even
like if if you run it from one workspace
to another, then the the skills are
different. The skill could be not
installed blah blah
like
That's what like a pro like
a product productization of open claw
would be like legit as like for example,
if you have Apple who have open claw
like system inside the Mac. Mhm.
That would be lit. Like
Alex Finn like talk about that in his
moonshot podcast.
Uh did you watch it? Yeah, I watched it.
He made a a question to the Apple devs
to do it. Exactly. So, that request like
having a
a hardware that have AI inside and in
when you go to the desk desktop and for
example, you have a meeting in 5
minutes, it can open the app or it can
write code an app
to go to the meeting that you have in 5
minutes. That would be Yeah, that would
be cool, but then everybody has the
exact same basic setup. You still need
to be able to add your own skills and
your own changes to make it work for
you. Yeah. Yeah, but like if if you go
as the level of the hardware, then you
can even have your own personal model on
your own machine or even like if you
have Yeah, if you have a dedicated
hardware
as powerful as like a Mac Pro Mac 5.
Mhm.
That's a new one. That's really a
personal computer. Yeah. Yeah, that will
be for sure. Yeah. I
I think
>> I'm just waiting for the models to go
because I think for when you need like
20 gigabytes of RAM right now.
So, you need at least 24 32 in your Mac.
Yeah. Uh I'm waiting for it to go to
four or eight.
No, no, no, but like
it's now I'm
they're working on that. Are are they
going to give us 2000
dollar Mac, but it will be like uh 200
VRAM whatever whatever. And then we will
have a model that would be within that.
Yeah, it's getting there. Every every
every week there is a new open source
model that drops anyway. So,
It will improve by itself. Yeah,
exactly.
But yeah, back to
GPT 5.4.
Yeah, I have a video to make out of
that. So, we are happy with it. Yeah.
Uh
tak tak. Okay, so that was
the announcement.
And we have the benchmark. Okay, so GPT
5.4 thinking and is that the Yes.
The uh
Uh GPT 5.4's
>> [snorts]
>> It's hard to say.
>> [laughter]
>> GPT 5.4 thinking and GPT 5.4 Pro are
rolling out now in chat GPT. GPT 5.4 is
also available in the API in and Codex.
Thank you.
Uh GPT 5.4 brings our advance in the
reasoning, coding, and agentic workflow
into one frontier model aka we don't
have
GPT Codex anymore.
Um
Which is Okay, so OS world verify by 75%
Codex 5.3 and Opus 4.6
uh
And
Opus 4.6 72 7 I didn't really I mean
yeah, like depend of this model, right?
This benchmark, but I didn't really
It's better, but it's not like I will
never use Opus 4.6 ever again because
5.4 is that better, right? Yeah. Yeah,
so you're waiting for Opus 4.7. Yeah.
They got They have to test it again.
Yeah.
But yeah, and also like they can
optimize for those benchmarks too,
right? So,
Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Uh
but yeah, so software engineer bench pro
57.7
and Anthropic didn't have that. Okay,
whatever. Cool. But it's still the best
and the other one the GDP Yeah, GDP
valve 83% which is like the GDP it's
like um
supposed to be
uh GDP
like the model is used into task that
will increase GDP.
Mhm.
So, yeah, 83%
and it's yeah, basically better than
anything else. Yeah, but first is 78%
that's that's a lot. Yeah, I know like
it's massive.
Like But I just I imagine like a model
at 90.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah. Like
mental.
And even like the jump from okay, GPT
5.3 codex 70 uh
71 to 83. That's almost 20% better.
Yeah. Yeah, it's 13. So, yeah, like
Yeah, yeah. Really? It's not really It
wasn't really but yeah. Yeah, yeah, it's
it's like 12% higher. So, 12% on on 71
that's a lot.
All right.
It's mental. And like yeah, this I think
this benchmark is one of the best, no?
Yeah, it is.
Uh
Okay, and browser comp. So, yeah,
browser comp is like the benchmark to
for everything that you do in your
browser. Mhm. But I'm a bit surprised of
yeah, 75 Okay. So, even like from one
one dot version
to another that's just massive jumps.
But yeah, okay. And Anthropic was yeah,
better than that. But I'm probably
because they have the
I mean uh They have the plug-in.
What?
Uh sorry, please continue.
No, but I
I wanted to say like they have a cloud
desktop. So, maybe that's why they have
the browser comp like benchmark. But
OpenAI has uh
uh
Atlas too. So, yeah, it's the same.
Yeah, but I never use Atlas. It was
giving so many issues I deleted it and
never tried it again.
I mean like cloud desktop, bro. Bro,
it's buggy as [__]
Yeah, but it was working for me. Yeah.
Because Like you know the chat is like
bro, you never had this issue?
>> Oh yeah, I had it. But I just have it on
the on the third monitor and let it run
because
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
It did a full adding of an app to the to
the iOS store for me.
A what? It added It did like a lot of
browser stuff for me like adding an app
to the iOS store and everything filling
in the forms and doing everything. Oh.
Damn, it submitted the own app.
Okay. Yeah. It did take it 1 and 1/2
hours because sometimes it's so slow.
Yeah. Yeah, but who cares?
Yeah, it did it for me. So, that was
cool. Yeah. Yeah, you can submit you
submit the app while you sleep and then
you don't have like to
fill up those [__] form stuff. But I
I can't wait to have um
uh
a CLI to submit a mobile app.
Yeah. You go full authentic yeah, full
API stuff and submit it and that's it.
But I think they will never allow it.
But Because people will spam it so much.
I mean
But that's where internet is going.
Yeah, but they check everything.
No, but they they can check. But then I
mean they will have AI to solve AI spam.
Yeah, so it will be like AI wars. Who is
the best one that can put in the most?
Yeah, you you're going to submit like
1,000 apps an hour and both AI will
compete to verify then reject and blah
blah blah. Yeah. I still think they will
will forbid you.
So, there will be a testing it to make
sure that you're human and you can only
submit one per hour or something.
Because otherwise it will take so much
computer on their side and so much
costs.
Is that Is that the benefit for Apple to
have like
1,000 apps an hour? I don't know. I
don't know because only the top
percentage will be used like the top 1%.
All the other ones are garbage. And even
if you create duplicates people are not
switching to duplicate apps.
Yeah, but you're still selling developer
licenses.
Yeah, but that's only one time 99 euros
per year, right?
Yeah. But yeah. Like I I have issue with
like those
um
limiting people
to do something on internet because
yeah, it's spam. But it's not a user
issue. It's like a
It's a app problem that need to figure
out the spam. Like for example
on X
um
Yes, there is bots. But then you also
open the API to bot activity. And if
there is not that many bots on X
you're never going to see a
um
a post with
uh 150 million views. So, you need the
bot to also spread
and reach way
to have way bigger numbers because you
still have like a
a stock price to increase.
You know what I mean? Yeah, so
eventually everything is just fake.
>> [laughter]
>> We're working on that, man. Yeah.
What's What's the truth? What's the
truth? You don't know because at the
moment there are also a lot of bots.
Yeah. And
But does that matter like to watch a
video that is completely fake anyway?
You know what I mean? Or a tweet or a
post or whatever. I mean if it's the
president of the United States that said
that okay, I'm going to invade France.
Yeah, that could be a problem. Yeah, it
has to be legit and it has to be
good information. But if there are so
many videos coming live, so how are you
even going to find
the ones that are correct?
Yeah. Um I mean it's like for TikTok
like if ByteDance is producing the best
video model Mhm. uh in 6 months she will
have what they've did with Sora to app
to TikTok.
Because that makes people create more.
Right? They don't need to film
themselves anymore. They can just prompt
it.
Yeah. And prompt themselves. Like Sora
to is TikTok too.
But uh
yeah.
Let's see how it goes. All right.
All right. I'm at the moment I am just
happy with my scraper installed on my
Mac mini. Because it can it now actually
scrapes website and it bypasses the
cloudflare protection.
Yeah.
That's big because normally companies
who scrape data
they do so much work on bypassing
the bot verification and now you can
just do it yourself.
Yeah, but like if
um
if you had yourself for agents scrappers
they are not visible anymore.
Like it drives traffic as [__]
Mhm. Okay. So,
um
also this app
I I sent that to you, right? Like for C
which is like
it's it's a AI to generate
a company.
When I sent that to you they were at 1
million in revenue. They are 3.5.
Yeah, and I asked them in the live chat
how they make money and they explained
it. Oh, yeah.
And what's the Yeah, like they want to
take a commission on like the revenue
generated to company, right? Yeah. So,
they say we only make money when you
make money. So, that's a plus plus.
Yeah. No, it's it's like yeah.
You're willing to completely give
10% 20% of your revenue when you go from
zero to
100 200 1,000 amounts without you doing
anything. Especially you just give an AI
an idea of a business and it goes. Yeah,
so it's free money even if you only get
80%. Okay.
But like yeah, like this It looks like
pop dot fun.
But did you try it? I didn't try it yet.
>> I didn't try it. I don't like I don't
understand like for example ads spend
3 cents
for that kind of losing clients because
my follow-up process was a mess. Studio
Pilot automated my intake and invoicing.
Now I land more clients with half the
admin work.
Like there is no call to action. It's
it's not a good video.
No, but it's automated with an AI. They
don't They just push so much data in. I
think it's it's more like throwing
it into a wall and see what sticks.
Yeah. Yeah, but like that's
uh 115
ads created in the past 24 hours fair
enough. But like okay, so this one spend
one one dollar
It's your 3.5 Okay, this one is even
better.
Uh thank.
If you've been wanting to learn trading,
but every video feels way too advanced,
this is exactly why I recommend Trader
Basics. It breaks everything down in a
simple way so you can actually
understand the foundation before jumping
into the market confused. If you want to
learn trading without all the
See, it it's [__] cut to the CTA.
Yeah, because it's it's at the max time.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, exactly.
Like Okay, so maybe just like okay
it's like MVP whatever whatever and it
cost you like
one year $1 you don't give a [__] about
it, right? So it's good. Um but
Yeah, I for me the product like yeah.
I mean you launch the product you're
making like 3 million in in sales.
Yeah.
But I doubt also mean like if you can
have 3 million with that
kind of product.
Uh
what the [__] am I doing?
Yeah, and
they just five coded this. That's what
looks like. Yeah, I mean he explained
like the design so in the podcast I
listened about that he said like the
design is
[__] but it remind me like one of the
game I played which is like paperclip
which is a game where you have to create
paperclip.
And it's an AI that create paperclip and
you buy tools to create more paperclips
blah blah and at the end of the game
um
it's it terraformed the uni
the universe to
create more paperclips because AI took
over and it was just made to create
paperclips.
And that's the kind of AI
they had
replicate that to create this dashboard.
It works.
It works. It works. But yeah, why why am
I talking about that? Yeah, like because
because it's make like running a company
autonomous
completely autonomous.
And
it's the same thing with like content
and everything that we have we discussed
before right and like the advancement of
the models like Yeah, but it also shows
other people are still screaming yeah AI
is only working for development and
coding and nothing else.
And even companies who say we don't
trust AI because of this this and this
and here you see these guys making three
and a half million.
So it works. You just have to go for it
and spend some time learning and
creating the skills. Yeah. No for sure.
Like
It's I don't know where we're going but
we're going.
Oh yeah, but if you are not trying it
right now and you're still waiting and
you come in in half a year and you are
so behind on how everything works.
Or you come back when like the models
are really really really good and like
GPT 10
and because the models are so good
the the gap like the advantage of us
being early Mhm. doesn't change at all
because the model is taking like is
getting way more like stuff anyway.
Yeah, that's true. It when you think
about something it creates it.
Yeah, it's like yeah create a GI make no
mistakes. Yeah, yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah. But
for crypto
it Solana has to be the payment of
agents. Mhm.
And like yeah if that happened that will
change the financial market.
Yes, then you are hoping that you have
1,000 SOL in your account.
Yeah.
But it will explode. Yeah.
I yeah exactly. I all of the agent
connected on in on internet that have
access to a Solana wallet.
And I think like the Coinbase
CEO mentioned it that uh
that was the next thesis.
Coinbase CEO
But
I never tried any crypto with AI
anymore. Did you?
No.
I I don't even know where they are.
Uh what's the what's the status but uh
you can say okay.
Very Okay. Very soon
there are going to be more AI agent than
human making transaction.
They they can't open a bank account but
they can own a crypto wallet.
Mhm.
4 million impression.
Yeah. That would be the biggest like
yeah it's going to be mental because
even like e-commerce bro.
Like you have an agent that doing
e-commerce going on Amazon reselling to
every [__] other platform on Earth.
Yeah, if you just have an agent
comparing prices and buying and selling
that's enough. Yeah. Yeah, you can you
can buy and sell
before the package moved.
Yeah.
So that's good enough, right? Yeah.
No that that that's there
and and even the timeline is like full
of uh
uh poly markets both that make that
printing money because that like it's a
bit
crazy because yeah like
where's the edge, right? But
Yeah.
Yeah, I never tried that one. No no I
mean I I try I have I still have a paper
trading bot but
yeah it makes me like 10 cents in
one month.
I guess it means that even the the
electric electricity is so much more
expensive.
>> [laughter]
>> But you can tell everybody you have a
bot making a profit. Exactly. Yeah, I
mean profit is profit, right?
Yeah, right. [snorts]
>> [laughter]
>> But yeah, that was the one of the
experiments
I tried post Christmas but yeah I don't
know like um
But you can't scale it, right? That you
say just do a thousand dicks. Yeah, no
no I just say like yeah create your I
don't want to touch it create your own
strategy make me money. And yeah make no
mistakes. Yeah.
It didn't work.
But
I didn't have time to look at it but
yeah like
Yeah, chat GPT 6 if it's like the Omni
model um where you speak to it and then
you have like multiple output and stuff
like where we are going from that?
Where
would you
would you would you like to see the
models go now?
What do you need
from the models? Well, every time I say
right now the model is good enough for
me to just keep going with my company
and just keep on building.
>> [clears throat]
>> And then a new model comes out and I say
within two days all the old model was
[__]
Yeah.
I'm just looking forward to how much
they can keep on scaling and
I think it's more like how much context
can you put into a request? How far can
it think and how many steps does it
know?
Yeah.
But okay, so because every Yeah, even
like maybe that's the that's why it's
also better than
uh office for
4.6 because
5.4 has a 2 million context window,
right?
Yeah, this yeah yeah it does and and
office 4.6 has 200k.
Yeah.
I thought of that. It's 10 more thing.
But
it's only that big on on the on the the
API, right?
Uh on the on the CLI? Oh yeah yeah yeah.
No, I I think we have 1 million.
Yeah, but 1 million is only by default
on the API. It's not in the CLI. The CLI
is smaller or you have to go to your
settings and do a custom setting to make
it bigger. Okay. Did you try it? Okay,
so and
Claude 4.6 already has a 1 million token
context window. Does it? Yeah.
Uh Opus and but I think Codex has a
bigger one.
Uh GPT
on 4.
Uh
Yeah,
yeah yeah.
I see.
Uh 1 million Okay, so wait
5.4 has a 1 million token context window
and Opus Yeah, but there is a
difference. Opus has a maximum context
window of 1 million tokens but by
default it's 200k unless the 1 million
context feature is enabled through the
API beta flag. So you can use the 1
million but
only the true devs who set up the
initial uh
setup and they make changes they can get
to the 1 million.
By default it has 200k but it's the same
thing for the
Codex 5.4. It says 1 million. It is by
default on the API and if you do the CLI
you have to change the settings. Yeah,
but like if you if you have a two
if the context window is too big then
the output is way shittier, right? I saw
I saw a thread about that too like with
a one guy say oh yeah look you need to
do that the right away and the other
guys were saying like no if you don't if
you do that then the output will be way
like not as good as it it is right now.
Yeah, I never tried it because I don't
like putting in that much
context. Yeah. I like to just make sure
that my requests are small so it can
give a better result. Yeah.
And and you can also like check it
that's it like faster anyway. Yeah, and
if people do it on the API and you just
put in push in everything
that will be a lot of tokens that you
have to pay. That's not like working
with an API
both both of them that's that's
Yeah, so people are screaming yay we
have 1 million." And then they get a
bill 2 days later and
they made no money. No, they have the
same bill like it's a 1 million
bill to pay.
>> Yeah, I guess.
So actually the only person winning is
Codex himself. I mean
I
Um the 200 subscription we pay Mhm. Uh
we get
um
the equivalent of like 1K or 2K in
in uh in tokens. Yeah, but do you all
the time use it? Yeah, I max out every
week.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh yeah, you are. Three accounts right
now. Yeah, I mean like the cloud, yes.
And I I I I have no idea what the [__]
I'm doing, honestly.
Because you don't have a maxing one,
right? No, and I have the $90 cloud and
uh I
And I only just one business is yet a
two business seats, but I only use one.
I I don't I don't understand.
I I I I don't know. I don't know. I
don't know. I need I I I I don't know. I
know. Like uh yeah, two two like Office
is way No, no. Codex is way better now.
Like today was like really like I I only
used 10%.
Uh after a full day of coding stuff, so
that was it. But
And yeah, also there is it multiple
times, but we'll see at the end of the
week. But
uh yeah, like for cloud, like like
token token token flying away. Yeah, but
you need to contain it because I'm
running two Mac minis.
And Codex and Cloud all day on CLI on
multiple projects at the same time
because I always have multiple screens
open, not just one terminal. Mhm.
And I never max out. Yeah. Uh the week
before I I think I had way too many
Chrome like when heartbeats running on
Open Cloud and that completely [__] up
my two accounts on Open Cloud. Then I
managed like to register it with A cool
sunny, whatever. Mhm. Um
But yeah.
Uh yeah, I came back from the weekend
from Friday to Monday like like
requesting here and there, you know? And
uh it went like 30% On Monday I was
already on 30% when my session was uh
You didn't even start up yet. Yeah,
[laughter] yeah.
I was not even in front of my computer.
It was just a question, can you get me
some coffee? Yeah, exactly. Like
uh Oh, I'm thinking about this feature.
What do you think?
>> Yeah. Let's build it.
Yeah. But like yeah, I mean
Uh okay, what what else what else
do we have? I'm lost.
Uh Notion deck.
Um
Do Do you know where they are going to
release
the sixth one? Sixth?
No. Did you hear any rumors? Yeah, like
the AI Grid uh YouTube channel uh talk
about uh six and the Omni model uh
stuff, which could be definitely
interest- interesting. Are you using
like the voice to walk?
Uh yeah, a little bit. When I know that
my
uh input is going to be long
I just use the speech to to write the
text. That's it.
Yeah. But I'm not speaking to my AI like
some people do. Yeah, not yet.
I mean
Yeah. That would be weird, right? If I
jump in Discord into my uh
uh voice channel and the AI comes in as
well and starts talking. I mean
That that's what's happened with uh
Henry and Alex Finn, right? So why not?
Yeah, yeah, why not? It is possible.
But yeah, what I need to do more is like
the recursive action now. Like uh
in plan, implement, and review.
Um I still I I would like to have a
proper IDE to do that instead of the
terminal. Mhm. So right now I have like
some um
uh commands and like hooks on Cloud. But
like for example on Codex CLI, I can't
use commands. Like we don't have like
commands like slash something
uh in the Codex CLI and I hate that
because for example I have uh on in
Cloud I have slash start and slash end
to document the session. Mhm. And I have
the control of it, but um
for Codex I have to tell document the
session. Annoying. Yeah, I think my
that's why I have a big notepad with
some standard Yeah. uh text in it that I
can just copy paste. Yeah, or you can
Yeah, with your Mac you can even like
have shortcuts.
Yeah, you can do it as well, but I never
did it.
>> Yeah, I mean either. Yeah.
Then I we should ask Cloud to
There is so much you can do. Yeah,
that's that. Uh okay, so uh uh
what else? I I have no idea what's going
to be the topic of the video, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh which model for which job? Yeah,
okay, okay. As a brain managing open
source model, yes.
Do you use open source model?
No.
I just wait for people to go bananas on
the open source models.
No, but like bro, like And then I will
try it, but
I So many.
But what I got from the Quen coder like
Quen three coders Mhm.
I I I think I told you last week, but
like I
I had the Open Cloud bots
trying to prompt it and then it told me
that it it gave back the prompt.
The bro, like
the [__]
So yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> I am not a bot, you are.
Yeah.
I will not work today.
>> [laughter]
>> Exactly.
But like Alex Finn is using
um
uh M2.5 Mhm. and uh Quen uh 3.5 on his
Mac mini.
I don't know exactly how he get those
output correct.
Yeah, but he is doing it full time. He
has the big ones with so much memory. He
can just give them big task and they
will run it. Yeah. And eventually it
also depends on he has them scraping the
the web all the time for new ideas.
>> Yes. So it's not that he is using them
for It's not a high reasoning task. It's
not coding.
Exactly. Yeah. So you can differentiate
what you want to do where. Yeah. I I
think I will have that for sales like
SDR
bots like agents.
Yeah, but right now I'm still I'm still
deep into coding and building features,
blah blah blah. Mhm. I Yeah, I don't
want to delegate that to open source
model, but having a 24/7 lead gen
that's sick.
But I also have some skills with a lot
of Python scripts in it, so it
doesn't need to do a lot of of research
and that would be perfect for the Quen
models.
Yeah, but like
um
it
Right now I think the Quen model are
still around like GPT
in term of benchmark they are 50%
instead of 70, you know?
Yeah, but for just scraping the web,
getting data, putting it in a skill,
running the Python models, get it out,
and then do a double check
for that stuff they are
good enough. Mhm. Yeah, for Yeah, no,
for sure.
Uh
But yeah, again for coding that you you
don't want to give them coding task,
right?
No, but yeah, and otherwise for creating
PDFs or for comparing CSV files or
whatever, they are perfect. Yes.
True. Okay, so yeah, mini max M2.5 high
reasoning 75.
And uh Cloud Office 4.5
77 768. That's crazy. That's not a big
difference.
Not exactly. Like uh you can use, but I
you can't use it as
uh
like it's not running on my Mac Studio
M2.
Yeah, I didn't try it yet. Yeah.
Uh
Oh, Office 4.6 is below. Jesus. Okay, Oh
yeah, I use really Okay, whatever.
Yeah, so it really is for for what task
are you running on it?
>> Yeah.
Not exactly. Yeah, but like if you have
open source model at that at those level
that run 24/7
Yeah. And just give them the task where
they can take the time. It doesn't need
to be done in 5 minutes. Yeah, not
exactly.
Or it can be like the vibe coder tools
that you you that you want to use, but
not the
um
Like the the small tools you want to
code for yourself. Like you want to vibe
code, you use M2.5 or M2 M3 later or
whatever.
And for the real SAS that you want with
like API or like full mono repo, blah
blah blah, then you use Yeah, 4.6. Yeah,
but right now you are doing the
heartbeat on Codex, right?
So the heartbeat is on A cool
because I had some uh issue with like
Quen I know I I think I switched to Quen
back, but yeah, the before weekend it
was on A cool, so I don't give a [__]
It's fine.
Uh but uh yeah, no, I have the heartbeat
on that connect
on my Mac Studio and back to the
instance.
So yeah.
Um okay.
Do we have to talk about anything else?
No, we did a lot. Yeah, I I don't I
don't know exactly what we talk about.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, but
We had a lot more written down.
But uh yeah, I know like uh
Yeah, whatever. That's cool.
Uh
okay, so is uh GPT 4.4
>> [laughter]
>> 5.4 the best model or or not? Yes, at
this moment it for sure is. Until next
week. Until next week.
>> [laughter]
>> But yeah, just let it keep on going. I
don't mind.
Uh I I can't wait for end of the after
end of the year.
Because by the end of the year we will
have we will have like GPT 67 whatever.
Mhm.
We will have uh Opus 6 or 7 something.
Maybe they're going to align the
numbers.
And we will have maybe one, two, three
more open source models.
And if the open source models by that
time have the same quality as 5.4 now.
Yeah.
Just get a 30 GB RAM Mac Mini, run it
all day long, and just use it for
everything.
Exactly. All right.
All right, we are we are getting a
uh employee like uh
full autonomous company for sure. Yeah,
the only thing you need is a good air
con to keep the temperature low. That's
it.
Is it getting hot in your in your room?
No, it's not. Yeah. But I know in the
summer because I have them here on my
desk and in the summer it's heating up
in Yeah, so Uh-huh.
I don't know how that influence the Mac
Minis, but
I I don't like Apple computer not good
with that.
Yeah, but they make so it sounds like
they are going to fly away.
I had it on my iMac and eventually when
I was going up like 38 degrees,
you would hear like the buzzing sound
and it was like a helicopter was taking
off. Damn, that's that
That's that I don't think me once when I
I was I I was going I was I run the the
AI run the QA locally.
Like the
um
by test and like uh uh
uh
end-to-end test. Mhm. It shut down my
computer like CPU was like
>> [laughter]
>> It was flashing up. Yeah.
Yeah, gone. Yeah.
Bye. Anyway, that's the AI age. And we
love it. Yeah, and if that is the
biggest issue, then let it come. Yeah,
[snorts] it's going to be fixed anyway,
so that's not a problem.
Bye, yeah man. Mitchell, thank you so
much for your time. Yes, thank you. Yes,
and uh yeah, bye everyone. Bye.